rated M for Mature
has this ever happened to you you can
suck into hell to marry Satan's daughter
then you need Saints Row gat out of hell
the latest and greatest standalone
expansion follow-up to the blockbuster
game about Saints rose and the roman
numeral four is that not normal this
game has it all witness a heroic tale of
how Johnny Gat himself ventures into
hell to save the President of the United
States from marrying Satan's daughter
get the must own title that you didn't
know you absolutely needed in your life
until right now fly like a majestic hell
angel hang out with historical figures
like Vlad the Impaler Blackbeard the
pirate and fictional ones like William
Shakespeare from all those movies about
poems and love used dozens upon dozens
of Hell related weapons neo superpowers
and brutal takedowns inspired by real
martial arts moves warning the use of
takedowns may result in the following
headaches swelling weight loss weight
gain weight lifting kitten death tube
steak cravings taxidermy repair bloody
eyes heart attack heart attack fever
scarlet fever smelly fever straight-up
fever 31 bean ice cream donut have a
dive instructor Stretton off real strong
HRBT twist ascoltare rusty trombone
basically you're [ __ ] think you might
be skipping some details but that's not
all we also have another game you
absolutely need to buy before anything
else in your life saints row 4 reelected
look at all this cool stuff that comes
jam-packed with extra grand hits nut
kicks with commands sharing in life
stream to polygon 666 times the counter
million p more resolutely speaking alien
obscure pop culture references or more
of everything sort of but twice the ass
three times the nut kick and infinity
more seen yaks coal crushing potential
it's the same classic saints row 4
experience you've come to know and love
reborn and ready to kick you in the nuts
on your fancy new gaming system with
literally hundreds of thousands of extra
pixels count them and see or wait till
someone on the internet does it for you
look at all this dick kicking look but
we're not done yet
if you call in the next three
milliseconds and get either saints row 4
reelected or double pack saints row 4
reelected and gat out of hell you also
get the executive privilege pack the
Wild West pack the enter the dominatrix
pack and every single DLC and pack that
has ever been released for saints row 4
ever how do we get one get the game that
everyone on the internet will be pixel
counting and dissecting frame by frame
order now operators are standing by
Saints Row gat out of hell saints row 4
reelected double pack saints row 4
reelected and get out of hell thank you
God